ROBERT MUELLER INVESTIGATION IS
INDEED A WITCH HUNT.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS,
THANK YOU.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
NANCY PELOSI LEADING A
DEMOCRATIC DELEGATION INTO THE
HEART OF THE IMMIGRATION STORM
TONIGHT.
THEY'RE VISITING A BORDER
FACILITY WHERE CHILDREN ARE
BEING HELD.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT WILL LOOM
LARGE IN S IS IN SAN DIEGO.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
IT'S ABOUT HUMANITY.
IT'S ABOUT FAMILY.
IT'S ABOUT WHO WE ARE AS A
COUNTRY.
>> FOR DAYS, DEMOCRATS FANNED
OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO HAMMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ZERO-TOLERANCE
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
>> IT IS APPALLING.
IT'S NOT AMERICAN.
IT'S UNNECESSARY.
>> IT IS ALSO NOT NEW.
THE DECISION TO PROSECUTE ANY
AND ALL WHO CROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY ACTUALLY BEGAN AS A
PILOT PROGRAM UNDER
PRESIDENT BUSH IN 2006.
>> THIS ZERO-TOLERANCE POLICY IS
INTENDED TO DETER PEOPLE FROM
BREAKING THE LAW.
>> CHIEF AGENT IN TUCSON.
ADVOCATES CLAIM HELP REDUCE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION MAKES
THE SAME CASE TODAY.
>> WE CANNOT AND WILL NOT
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO BRING THEIR
CHILDREN OR OTHER CHILDREN TO
THE COUNTRY UNLAWFULLY BY GIVING
THEM IMMUNITY IN THE PROCESS.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION HOPES
ZERO-TOLERANCE WILL REDUCE
FRAUD.
>> WE DO NOT HAVE THE LUXURY OF
PRETENDING THAT ALL INDIVIDUALS
COMING TO THIS COUNTRY AS A
FAMILY UNIT ARE IN FACT A
FAMILY.
>> HOMELAND SECURITY CLAIMS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FRAUDULENTLY
USING CHILDREN TO POSE AS FAMILY
INCREASED 315% THIS FISCAL YEAR,
EXPLOITING A LOOPHOLE TO ESCAPE
DEPORTATION AND PROSECUTING
THOSE CASES, THE DEPARTMENT
SEPARATED SOME 1200 CHILDREN
FROM AN ADULT.
>> THE SMUGGLERS AND TRAFFICKERS
KNOW THE LOOPHOLES BETTER THAN
CONGRESS.
>> CRITICS SAY TRUMPET
SEPARATING CHILDREN NOT TO
CHANGE THE LAW BUT AS A
BARGAINING CHIP TO FUND HIS
WALL.
>> HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO WOULD
RESCIND THIS ZERO INHUMANITY
POLICY IMMEDIATELY?
>> MOMENTS AGO, THE
ADMINISTRATION STRESSED THAT
ENTERING THE U.S. WITHOUT
PERMISSION IS A CRIME.
BASICALLY, THE PROBLEM IS WHEN
YOU DETAIN WOMEN AND CHILDREN,
THE COURTS HAVE SAID THAT YOU
HAVE TO RELEASE THEM WITHIN 20
DAYS THROUGH THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS CONGRESS TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE SO FAMILIES CAN STAY
TOGETHER.
WHAT WE HEARD FROM DEMOCRATS
TODAY IS THEY WANT TO BAN THE
PRACTICE AND THEY BELIEVE
FAMILIES SHOULD BE HANDLED